avec mon prochain invité on va aller de
Val d'Or à Cannes sataki vous avez
compris qu'on va parler de la question
autochtone commençons par Valdor le 15
mai dernier lors d'une séance du conseil
municipal de Val d'Or dans une salle
remplie de citoyen inquiète par la
montée de la violence le député caquiste
d'Abitibi pierre Dufour à critiquer la
façon dont la mairesse gérait les
problèmes différents c'est de
délinquance au centre-ville il a aussi
dénigré au passage le reportage de
l'émission Enquête sur les femmes
autochtones
en plus de critiquer les travaux de la
commission vient qui étaient chargés
d'examiner les relations entre les
autochtones et certains services publics
écoutons-le
vous avez travaillé avec un taux de
merde depuis que vous êtes arrivés à
poste qui a été créé particulièrement
depuis 2015 quand il y a eu une émission
enquête qui est un émission bourrée de
Mantry qui a attaqué des policiers qui
étaient très honnêtes je dis pas qu'il y
avait peut-être pas eu quelques
policiers vers eux une trentaine
d'années auparavant mais qui ont été
attaqués
le député s'est excusé mais plusieurs
appellent toujours à sa démission c'est
le cas de l'Assemblée des Premières
nations et Québec solidaire le Premier
ministre pour sa part juge ses excuses
suffisantes
je pense que bien fait de s'excuser ce
que je déplare dans ce dossier là c'est
qu'on a fait toujours de ramener ça un
enjeu racisé ce n'est pas un dossier
racisé c'est un dos dans l'itinéraire il
y en a de toutes les couleurs il y a
toutes sortes de gens quand on est rendu
dans du vent d'Alice dans de l'agression
et dans de la délinquance on parle plus
du même type de situation et ce n'est et
ce n'est pas seulement que l'aspect
autochtone il y a des allochtones aussi
là-dedans on s'attend à ce qui contribue
à des pistes de solution sur des enjeux
complexes des enjeux de société que ce
soit l'itinérance les problèmes de santé
mentale et l'impact que ça là sur une
population l'insécurité la violence la
délinquance bien qu'il contribue avec
avec nous tous sur le terrain à la
recherche de solutions et non pas
devenir miner le travail qui se fait
alors mon invité est le ministre Yann
Lafrenière responsable des relations
avec les Premières nations les élus de
bonsoir Monsieur la première merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation bonsoir
vous êtes un ancien policier je pense
que c'est une expérience qui est
importante à souligner dans le dossier
actuel madame Poutier qu'on vient
d'entendre avec d'autres signes de
lettres aujourd'hui déplorant l'état de
la situation comme une déclaration comme
cela est extrêmement nuisible le même
dit à nos collègues de la radio en
Abitibi que ça rouvrait des plaies
béantes que ces déclarations là vous le
communiste ça doit changer un peu le
portrait pour vous là vous avez beaucoup
de rattrapage à faire de reconstruction
de pont à faire
mon collègue Pierre Dufour s'est excusé
l'avouer cette exprimée sur le coût de
l'émotion je le crois je crois parce que
pas longtemps j'étais avec Madame
Claudie on faisait l'annonce pour
l'agrandissement du centre de Monsieur
autochtone de Valda cependant je vous
confirmer madame soul je suis en totale
des accords avec ce que mon collègue dit
lors de cette rencontre lors de cette
séance bien que je conçois le que des
enjeux à Valdor des enjeux qui sont
importants et plusieurs citoyens qui
l'ont mentionné des enjeux d'incivilité
des enjeux de criminalité c'est vrai
mais effectivement il y a pas de lien à
faire entre ça et les relations
autochtones à l'automne et ça je vous le
confirme pour ce qui est de ces
allégations envers la commission vient
envers les missions enquête je répondrai
avec deux faits importants vous avez
mentionné mon passé de policier en 2015
j'étais au SPVM j'ai été déployé à Val
d'Or pour soutenir le groupe d'enquête
qui était à Val d'Or donc de faire le
lien qui communauté de faire le lien qui
est victime potentiels et nonobstant le
résultat de l'enquête qui est important
c'est que des façons de travailler qui
ont changé complètement Val d'Or entre
autres avec
que c'était mis sur place puis par la
suite il y en a eu d'autres qui ont été
déployés au Québec alors il y a de
grands changements suite à 2015 ça c'est
un fait mais pour un gars du coin
j'ai fait des effets des excuses pas
perçu nécessairement comme des excuses
par tout le monde a dit je suis à 99 %
avec tes conclusions du rapport viennent
sauf que
possède ou bien la commission vient de
dire qu'on donne trop de contraventions
aux autochtones commençaient politique
trouvez-vous qu'on donne trop de
contrats mais en question quand même la
commission vient là il refait les
missions enquête qui est venu de grands
changements sur la façon de travailler
quand je parle d'une Thémix que les gens
nous comprennent à la maison on parle
donc de policiers de la santé du Québec
ici autochtone de travers socio qui
travaille ensemble à Val-d'Or c'est un
modèle qui est inspiré d'unité qu'on à
Montréal et par la suite c'était déployé
ailleurs au Québec donc une vision
différente quand on travaille en matière
de différence faut trouver des solutions
vous avez raison est-ce que des fois ce
que est-ce que l'émission de constat va
vraiment régler le problème absolument
pas ce qu'on travaille avec des
travailleurs sociaux pour ce qui est de
la Commission on l'a confirmé depuis une
interview pour voir 49 actions concrètes
qui nous permettent de répondre en tout
en partie à 86 recommandations pourquoi
je sors des chiffres comme ça je vais
vous démonter qu'on est dans l'action on
fait des choses concrètes je disais
encore une fois je suis en total des
accords avec les propos de mon collègue
en même temps les demandes de démission
vont continuer
c'est comme si le bureau des excuses
étaient ouverts au gouvernement c'est
pas une fois que Monsieur le goutte
obligé de cautionner des excuses avec ça
pas contents les excuses c'est ce qu'il
y a du je m'excuse ça fait mal mais ça
devrait retirer carrément c'est pas faux
je comprends les réaction des
partenaires moi-même la semaine dernière
j'ai écrit à l'ensemble des partenaires
que ce soit les chefs de banque que ce
soit les partenaires entre autres que ça
soit la piole le centrechtone pour
expliquer mon total des accords avec les
propos et de réitérer contenant l'action
comme je vous dis encore une fois il y a
des changements concrets c'est vraiment
pas terminé et valder ça demande un
enjeu j'ai parlé la mairesse avec mes
collègues Lionel Karman François
bernardel on travaille des solutions
terrain et quand on parle d'itinérance
et l'itinérance que je vais appeler
locale l'équivalence de passage si moi
je l'ai connu comme policier à pas mal
il y a des gens qui se déplacent à
Val-d'Or et pourquoi c'est si différent
mais d'agir quelqu'un qui vient pas du
coin qui reste pas sur place et
complètement
différente
Park que ce soit près du square Cabotte
cependant pour Valence je vais être bien
précis mais j'étais à Val d'Or de ce 2
semaines oui il y a des gens qui sont en
situation destinérance du côté
autochtone et on aide beaucoup les
organisés sur place mais ce n'est pas un
problème autochtone c'est vraiment un
problème d'itinérance et d'insubilité
que sur place un mot sur quel est
s'attaquer il doit y avoir une réunion
ce Conseil de banque aujourd'hui il y a
une manif de gens qui jouent au
ping-pong masqué là vous le savez tout
le monde se relance la balle qu'est-ce
qu'on fait avec ce Conseil de banque qui
ne peut rien faire à l'endroit de ses
propriétaires ou détenteurs de permis
enfin les deux frères Gabriel là liés au
crime organisé
il y a plusieurs enjeux qui connaissent
attaquer c'est un dossier qui dure
depuis une trentaine d'années ce que
changé récemment vous parlez du Conseil
de banque qui est complètement
dysfonctionnelle puisque c'est un enjeu
qui est majeur cependant moi ce qui me
rassure c'est que de voir que de plus en
plus de langues se délient les gens sur
la place publique il semble y avoir un
consensus qu'il faut faire quelque chose
vous parler de generic qui est un enjeu
qui est majeur on agit en passant on a
retiré le permis on a fait en sorte
qu'il y ait plus de matière qui soit
déversées c'est encore sur place mais
écoutez le danger dans tout ça tant que
les frères Gabriel sont propriétaires
vont exercer une propriété sur les lieux
imaginez comment les gens seraient pour
eux sont décontaminés à coups de
plusieurs millions puis qui
recommençaient à polluer par la suite
donc c'est pour ça qu'on cherche une
solution dès la semaine prochaine je
rencontre ma collègue papy I do du côté
fédéral on peut trouver une solution
ensemble mais ça passe pas plusieurs
choses le Conseil de banque on a un
enjeu qui politique sur place on a un
enjeu de sécurité mon collègue François
bernardel s'y attelle avec la Sûreté du
Québec plusieurs enjeux à connaissent
attaquer mais moi je postive depuis mon
arrivée en poste la première nomination
que j'ai faite c'est Monsieur Paul
Gérard comme négociateur facilitateur un
ancien possible de la santé du Québec en
qui j'ai complètement confiance pour
trouver des solutions parce que ça dure
depuis 30 ans les solutions datant les
actions les gestes pour amener la paix
sur ce territoire merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation monsieur la première à
bientôt au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI